from when i was reading your paper if i
understand correctly it's something like
the bfss matrix models but then what i
was wondering is
and this is my rudimentary knowledge
that the
a more general form of bfss is bmn
and it takes into account turn simon's
term and so on and it also is not in
minkowski space it's in ppwave which to
me sounds as if it's more general
so i'm curious why didn't you use the
bmn model why did you choose to use bfss
good question i mean right now we're not
choosing in fact we're not even choosing
we're just trying to figure out okay
the idea is that there are all these
matrix models as you said bmn bfss ikkt
what we're really focusing on is to
actually liberate ourselves from really
um
we really want to
use that as a motivation
but not yet um
commit ourselves to any one of those
models actually
so the matrix model that we actually did
commit ourselves to is something called
a cubic matrix model
um
and that was actually
authored by uh you know motivated by lee
smolin so the idea would be in this
cubic matrix model is that
you have um
you know
you have a lagrangian
okay
um
that has a matrix let me call this thing
um
a matrix
x
and so now but this matrix actually has
a kinetic term x dot squared now i'm
suppressing the mn indices here so it
has
okay
i'm suppressing it so it has kinetic
energy
and then it will have a potential
that depends on x except this potential
is cubic in x
so it's cubic in a sense because it's a
matrix
it's a commutator right
like this
because matrices remember their matrix
values so the products will be
commutators
and as a result the equations of motion
of these matrices
you know the dynamics of these matrices
classically
will be something that looks like x dot
right
is
there's some there's probably some
coupling here let me call it lambda is
going to be lambda
you know
x comma x
because i i have to take a derivative
with respect to x
and if you look at this thing here
right
the idea is that
you know if you look at this here this
is like
i want to now think of this x dot
as my y
right
okay and and somehow this
you know this um
x x commutator right
could be massaged into something that
looks like y
times a component of x
right that's the analogy here
okay
now we're not there yet okay so the idea
is that somehow the dynamics of a matrix
model
is
similar to the dynamics of like a you
know of basically how a neural network
um
is able to learn and um
to learn
maybe in a supervised way so in other
words if i present the sum the theory
with an output or something known so
like a known solution yeah the idea is
that can the theory maybe spit out new
solutions
okay or for example here's one one thing
we're playing with
um imagine that these matrix models
could spit out realizations of the
standard model so in other words because
they're n by n matrices
you know um so therefore it might
correspond to a group s u n or special
unitary group n
then you can imagine that basically s23
times sc2 cross
may pop out as solutions of this theory
okay
um and the idea would be like given that
we know that this is a solution right
you think of that as the output
the same way we present a picture of a
cat or a dog and have the
neural network learn that
the same way we uh we're using the
matrix model and the dynamics of the
matrix model itself
right
as a learning
architecture so there's nothing external
to the system it's sort of like you know
in it's part of the system itself via
its dynamics its equations of motion
um and the idea here is if you if you're
on a one-to-one correspondence between a
learning architecture via neural
networks
um and
the dynamics of the matrix model
if we're able to make this
correspondence between x and and you
know this correspondence okay right
um so let me see if i can make this a
cleaner statement here so on one side i
have a artificial neural network and
right it has dynamics why maps
and i'm sorry you know input
sure
goes to output
and then what happens is that what's
going on here
the weights then get adjusted so the
weights are the things that actually get
adjusted in this learning right the
weight get optimized
likewise if i have a matrix model
and then there's something like the
standard model
as a solution
can we use
can we use um
can we use the dynamics
can we use um let me see hold on a
second
in the paper did you focus or restrict
yourself to restricted boltzmann
machines or did you try out others
so far we um we restricted ourselves to
um
hot feel like models
which um in some cases can be adapt you
know can be made
um
[Music]
can have a semblance or you know rbms
restricted both machines i see and
there's uh the reason for that is just
simplicity
the reason for that is um generality
generality and and um it's yeah and
simplicity at the moment but we're
definitely keeping an eye out for other
other ways but let me so this that's
right so the idea here is that this
correspondence here is
instead of input output via the you know
um artificial neural network
right um the matrix model the diff the
input now would be
the dynamic like the equations of motion
so we use the equation of motion itself
as a learning mechanism and the idea now
is that what are the weights how are the
weights being adjusted and we the idea
here is that
the things that get adjusted might be
the parameters of the standard model
because one of the big unresolved things
and
in um
theories of everything and like string
theory or even brand unified theories is
that you can spit out solutions or
realizations of the standard model but
as you know because of the latin this
issue of the landscape it's hard to tune
those parameters
so we're saying okay embrace that
but really what's going on maybe that
the universe is actually
learning and you know
um it somehow
you know
finds a solution if the solution is
stable in some sense stable meaning that
it's it's because these weights are
being adjusted
um
and the idea could be that um these
weights
that are being adjusted will correspond
to the parameters of the standard model
so it's a big dream at the moment
and it's a research program but we're
kind of in the middle of it right now